hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent game to share with you from a
historic match between IBM supercomputer
deep blue and Gary Kasparov
this was their very first game and it
was played on February 10 1996 in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania
and it set a record it was the first
time a computer program defeated a world
champion in a classical game under
tournament regulations that is with
classical time controls
let's have a look
E4 C5 Sicilian Defense alapin Sicilian
the C3 Sicilian
okay one of the main replies to the C3
Sicilian
is to play D5
black is saying I'm okay
bringing out the queen early I don't
have to worry about Knight C3 now that
you have a Pawn on C3
D4
King Knights are out
how is black treating this allopin
variation he's going with
the PIN
how's this dealt with first the breaking
of the pin and then this bishop is given
a kick white gains just a little bit by
flicking that one in more long term it's
nice to have the flight Square for our
King once castled
from here castles Knight C6
and once this guy is on E3 and there is
this increased pressure on C5 that's
when black
releases the tension takes on D4
and white takes on the isolated Pawn
recaptures with the pawn
now in preparing for this video one of
the lines I wanted to have a look at is
you know I questioned whether it was
necessary for black to release the
tension it's not
but you do have to be careful
this is another move that black could
consider here
not with the intention to meet ponte's
Pawn with Bishop takes Pawn because that
would be losing a piece Queen takes
Queen and then
Bishop takes Bishop
however black could follow with Queen
takes Queen and then look to bother this
Bishop from its defensive C5 some of the
lines from here get very messy
my point black has options after Bishop
to E3
in this game it's
C takes D4 straight away
C takes D4 now this is opened
the tempo against the queen is nearby
Bishop B4
A3 both Bishops have been deployed to
similar spots here for black
both have been kicked back
and now I thought the idea with this
bishop deployment by black to B4 was to
chop the Knight
as soon as it goes to C3 so much for
that the queen simply reacts so what is
the idea
that black has the bishop is looking to
reroute to B6
to create more pressure against the
isolated Pawn
okay
from here Knight B5
black now has to be very careful where
to go exactly with the queen
in the game it's Queen E7
it's important for black to stay out of
reach of this Knight
if this guy is allowed to get to E5 and
generate a threat against the queen
that's going to be problematic for black
as an example
here's a line you don't want to
have to play as black
takes takes and now if you take this
Knight
there's going to be a big problem on D6
so Knight takes Pawn takes the Knight is
hit
and then you're gonna go on castled
so you don't want to in short have to
take the Knight when it gets to E5
having to deal with the pawn on D6
scaring away the Knight on F6 and
creating a support point on D6 is way
too much for black to handle so again
it's best to stay out of reach of this
King Knight
from here 95 still goes just not as
forcefully
Bishop takes Bishop
Queen takes Bishop
castles
and Rook a to C1 so
these are the two files to put the Rooks
which one do you go with first queen
Rook belongs on C1 the king Rook belongs
on D1 this is the one that gives
direction to Black
a threat is now present on C6
it's defended okay to C8
and now Bishop to G5 so
this valuable Tempo earlier Knight B5
hitting the queen
is making this second step with the
bishop possible went to E3 now it's
being redeployed on this diagonal the
Knight is pinned the Knight on B5 is
defending D4
how's black going to deal with that
he goes with B6 completing this journey
with the bishop it now pinpoints D4
this is where black starts to go
a bit wrong computer is suggesting that
A6
is best to immediately Drive the Knight
back
or at least try to kick this Knight back
very soon
best continuation from here is to First
flick in this capture if A6
note that black is not in a position to
recapture the queen there would be a
fork on D7
so black would have to take with the
pawn
and after Knight takes Rook takes it
says go back
here
that's considered one of the best
continuations
in this game however the bishop goes to
B6
and now comes Bishop takes Knight
you still can't take with the queen
because of the fork on D7
Pawn takes Bishop
and now Knight to C4
so
maybe black in this position was
thinking
that the Knight would have to go back to
F3
to defend this point directly
but white has indirect defense of D4 now
that this king is more exposed
there is after all a
open file there's no G Pawn there's some
checks here
White's reply is to go to C4
looking to track down this bishop
looking two in a way create a whole
for this Knight on B5
once this captures in and if these guys
end up doubled there is no a pawn there
is no A6
so
in the game we have Rook F to d8 I said
this is indirectly defended
how so
if you take with the Knight or Bishop
it's not going to matter
this is how white would win the piece
check
there goes the bishop
indirect defensive D4
so black throws a third piece on it
by this point White's able to swipe the
bishop and create another structural
defect in Black's camp
and this guy is now stable
from here
Rook F to D1 last piece involved
F5 cuts out any check and also opens up
a new square for the queen
E3 Queen F6 the new Square
that was opened up with F5
and now we have
a key move in this game
D5 at the end of the video
I'll share more about this Pawn break
I'll actually just go ahead and quote
Gary
about this move towards the very end
it's
uh very instructive what he has to say
about this Advance let's see how this
plays out
Rook takes Pawn
Rick takes Rook
Pawn takes rook in B3
so
you could capture on B6 but that would
not be a good idea because black would
get this Pawn right back and that would
not be a an even trait of Pawns because
this guy right here is
really just a half Point pun since it's
doubled and isolated and this is a full
point Pawn
so white saves the healthier Pawn
and now this is nearby
from here King h8
getting ready to make use of this half
open G file
notice instead of King h8 if black tries
D4
white could simply take there is after
all this pin against the Knight
okay so in the game it's King h8
Queen takes B6 only now Rook G8
Queen C5
if you try some other move like grabbing
another Pawn
Black's gonna be winning
Queen G5
would win the game double attack rook
and mate and you cannot defend both
okay
so it's Queen C5 the queen is coming to
the rescue looking to take on D5 in
defend G2
so that would be a good follow-up in the
event of Queen G6
or queen G7
considered best in this position is
Queen to G5
pressure here it's not
uh well it is defended in this case with
the queen on C5 rather than B7 so
there's just this one threat but this
was considered the best line to and in
fact go for the maintenance one threat
and some line with G3
F4 and then Knight to D6 so I think
maybe this was a reason
maybe one of the reasons black didn't go
for this this idea of a mate thread on
G2 it does leave F7 extra sensitive
white has a serious Fork Threat all of a
sudden
so no G no Queen G5 in this game instead
D4
Knight D6
F4 Knight takes Pawn we're ready to take
the Knight and defend the Knight gets
out of the way
it looks a bit scary here there are
these two past connected past pawns but
they're a long ways away
there's this guy who's three steps away
a battering ram possibly with F3
aggressive pieces and puns black has
this guy is also poison discovered
checks
okay
from here Queen D5 accurate defense is
required by white and it is of course
found this defense
from here F3 G3
and now in the game we have Knight to D3
I have a pop quiz for you
and that is what would you play as white
if black went with Queen F4
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video there's only one winning move can
you spot it
feel free to pause the video
okay
the best move
is Rook to ca
so one of the things you can be looking
for in situations like this
you know
you're playing as white you see that
this Pawn is pinned
we would like to take the queen can we
play a move like Queen takes Rook can we
knock that pinning piece out while we
can't can't jump upon but we could
say yeah let's pin the pinning piece
that's maybe another thing you could
look into so that's a really fancy uh
continuation really fancy move there the
idea is to prevent this sacrifice on G3
that was a serious threat by black in
this position
and Rook C8 is a perfect way to defend
against that
okay
Rick takes Rook we would take the queen
alright in this game Knight D3 is played
Rook C7 same story if Queen F4 is played
in this position Rook C8
from here is Rook E8 Knight D6 this guy
is definitely in the crosshairs three
pieces on it black now goes all in with
the check King H2 Knight takes F2 these
three alone are ready to weave the mate
Rook H1
game over white must be timely and of
course is
capturing nf7 with check
in the game
King G7 is played what other options are
there
let's look at the worst one
King G8 would result in a maintenance
two Knight H6 double check and then
Queen G8 mate
if Queen takes Knight we can't take the
queen because we'd be getting mated
so how would white reply there's only
one winning continuation and that would
be to give this check the Rook is on the
seventh let's get the other major piece
on the eighth
what are the options here for black
let's look at them
King G7 we would now be able to take the
queen because it's with check
and then we could land this Fork against
the king and Pawn
King G7 swiping the pawn stops the main
threat Rook H1
is now met with King G2
some other continuation
at this stage after the night check
Queen takes here if the Rook blocks
well we no longer have to worry about
the mate threat
and we could Parry this threat against
our Queen first by giving this check
winning a pawn would chuck
and next winning the queen
and the last moves to look at are the
queen blocks
okay well the simplest one you go to f8
it's making one
and if you go to one of these two you
give up control of f six and it will be
a main two
with Queen F6
Queen G7 game over
so we got all the lines covered there in
the game
it's King G7
walking into the discovered check
King H6 is played if you're going to G6
there's a check on G8
I'll be highlighting A variation shortly
with Queen G8
in this game it's King H6 and now Rook
takes H7
that's the final move of this one black
resigns
if the game continued
King G6 we can sweep into
G8 and
it may be tempting to view this position
as white and think
oh how am I supposed to win the queen or
what's the mate threat well you don't
have to
go for those two things you could look
to Simply Parry the mate in one threat
by black and when you do that you buy
yourself more time to go hunting for the
queen or King
white would have a move like Knight
takes Pawn in this position no more mate
and many threats now for black to Parry
Knight takes Rook the pin and win of the
queen or simply going hunting for the
king
no solution here for black
so I want to go back to this key moment
and share with you this quote
by Gary and that is at this point right
here move 23 this Pawn sacrifice right
here move 23
and D5 so this is what he had to say
about this 23rd move he said quote
if I had been playing White
I might have offered this Pawn sacrifice
it fractured Black's Pawn structure
and opened up the board although there
did not appear to be a forced line of
play that would allow recovery of the
pawn
my instincts told me that with so many
loose black ponds and a somewhat exposed
black king white could probably recover
the material with a better overall
position to boot
so
I hope you enjoyed this quote from one
of the greatest minds of the game there
were points that stuck out to me about
it his phrase
there did not appear to be a forced line
of play
as well as my instincts told me
and his use of the term probably
it does give us a nice window into his
intuitive thinking about this key
position
of a historic game
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye